well to be honest with you i didn't
really
know that reality shows existed still uh
really that's that's how plugged into
the entertainment world i am but my
producers inform me that reality shows
are still very much a thing and uh
they're all their age in fact and they
had the bright idea to have me watch
some reality show
trailers and react to them and i can
only assume because they're the ones who
suggested it that i will hate every
minute of this because that's the only
type of content they ever do suggest
because i guess everyone enjoys watching
me
in pain watching me suffer so i've
steeled myself i think i'm ready
as ready as i can be
let's uh let's go i love you to death
but i just cannot wait any longer that
is why i'm giving this ultimatum
you're here because someone in your
relationship has issued an ultimatum
you're not sure you want to marry your
current partner the risk is that they're
going to find someone else who is
i think it's natural to wonder what it
would be like to be in a different
relationship
you'll each choose a new partner you're
moving together in a trial marriage and
at the end of this experience you guys
will have to choose
to marry the person you've arrived here
with or to split forever
today we get to move in with someone
completely different living with a guy
that's not you will be a weird change
how do you feel about me sleeping in the
bed
are you nervous to meet my dad hope they
don't grill me too hard hi
this is the first time i felt like okay
this guy's okay from what he said about
you i was not happy about this at all
this is our first morning back together
we came here as a couple but it's about
figuring out what's best as individual
people okay
i'm already 20 points 20 iq points
dumber and we just started i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be a sea sponge by the end of
this thing we'll give you the new member
initiation
what is even the premise here so you've
got you've got uh what's his name joey
fatone hosting this and you've got
couples who want to get married and so
they come on a reality show
and they shack up with somebody else for
a while on camera to find out if they
should marry the other person is that do
i have this right we want to get married
and to find out if we should get married
we're going to go and we're going to go
and live with somebody else on a
well i can answer the answer the
question for you right now you shouldn't
get married okay spoiler
all of you are awful
um none of you should get married you
should all move into the wilderness by
yourselves and save society from having
to endure your presence that's what
should happen here
so it needs to happen
how is it that reality shows are dumber
now than i remember them being i think i
just i i couldn't handle living in a
world where this kind of stuff exists so
i blocked it out of my mind and i and i
went to i went to my safe space my happy
space and now um now i have to confront
this and it's even worse than i remember
but uh let's uh let's watch the next one
i've met the person i want to spend the
rest of my life with
i've never seen her before
here you will choose someone to marry
hello nice to hear from you can't say
see ya without ever
24 7. if you're ready to find the love
of your life
game time the pods
are now open
what kind of work do you do what are
some of your biggest turn offs so what
are you looking for in a woman ethnicity
race physical appearance none of that
matters i'm really starting to
emotionally connect with you this could
be a remarkable love story
you're a beautiful person i don't have
to see you to say that
i'm scared of making the wrong decision
you can't see my life without you will
you be my wife
[Music]
i am engaged to somebody i've never seen
before
i hope these just find me very
attractive
can they just just lock the cubes and
just leave them in there
we can watch them slowly starve to death
that would be a reality show and does
joey fatone host all these shows now i
thought he was dead i don't know they
have them chained up in a basement
somewhere and they bring them out like
the [ __ ] and pulp fiction whenever
there's a new netflix reality show and i
say new reality show but really there
has never been a new reality show i
think all these ideas are just versions
of each other what about american idol
but they have to write their own song
love it oh uh what about american idol
but they have to write their own songs
love it we're going to match a bunch of
attractive people up and have them
get married even though they haven't
seen each other i wonder what will
happen we know what happened they'll get
divorced by next thursday that's what's
going to happen second of all the drama
and suspense is taken out right because
they're all relatively attractive
i mean that's what this is all about
it's like well what does a person look
like
i mean for a concept like this to work
you need to mix in some some ugly
ducklings they need to be in this mix
here
so you should have like
a guy who's 600 pounds and they wheel
him out on a forklift for the big reveal
you've already gotten married and you're
married to a 600 pound guy on a forklift
that would be high drama instead
everybody is in the seven to nine range
as far as physical looks go
so the show is what will happen when
these sevens to nines meet other sevens
to nines nothing interesting
i could already tell you that yeah i'll
be honest guys this job uh gets really
hard sometimes all day long i watch
debunk and cancel stupid people some
days my producers make me sit behind
this desk for hours on end watching
purple-haired weirdos attempt to explain
their gender-neutral pronouns to me it's
no easy task and uh the only way that
i've found to cope with all this torture
is with hallo hallo is the number one
christian prayer app in the u.s it's
like calm or head space but rooted in
catholic faith as opposed to the
religion of leftism hallow offers over 5
000 audio guided prayers meditations and
christian music tracks some of the most
popular daily prayers are the daily
rosary gospel reading of the daily psalm
with bishop baron and so much more paulo
helps me find peace and calm throughout
the day even as crazy leftists yell at
me through a tiny screen go to hello.com
matt walsh get an extended three-month
free trial during which you'll have
access to all 5 000 plus meditations and
prayers that's hallow.com matt walsh for
three months free reclaim your piece in
this crazy world download hello today
okay continue deep in the remote jungles
of colombia a new species has been
spotted at the watering hole humans a
rare sight in this habitat these humans
are using animal mating techniques in
their search for true love
and are forbidden to speak to one
another
[Music]
not talking sucks
[Music]
my inner animal is an otter because
they're super playful i'm a tiger i have
a big appetite i'm trying to eat ducks
are kind of like majestic but also kind
of goofy i feel like i'm a mix between
the two
okay everything's about to get
interesting a little spicy
[Music]
it was very weird but very sexy and
weird i think this is a new fetish for
me i guess mating rituals work because
i've never been so attracted to step on
before
uh i want to be dead
i just want to be dead now um
i'm in such deep despair in this moment
and it's not even how stupid the show is
like it's that's not the problem it's
that people i assume watch this and
those people are among us
they walk among us they they vote
they drive
it's possible that i've accidentally
been polite to somebody who watches this
show well probably not me i have not
played anybody but you know it's still
god help us but why should god help us
we've forsaken him
so why should he help
us right go ahead
[Music]
what's up y'all it's lizzo i'm looking
for dancers to join me on my tour girls
that look like me don't get
representation time to pull up my
sleeves and find them myself
we think and we pretty and we know what
we bout it's the battle
of the big girls
to be a background dancer for lizzo
would just mean everything
[Music]
it's show time
hey ladies
what do we have in store this is the fun
part
i'm always doubting myself and i feel
like that has been detrimental and how i
approach dance
you know this is how bad it's gotten
that's actually refreshing compared to
the others lizzo and a bunch of obese
dancers and thongs and spandex
that is that's a sight for sore eyes
compared to
what we saw before
compared to the mental sewage that came
before it
you know what i really want to say i
want to see
the contestants of that show
mixed in with the contestants on the
love is blind show
that's the show i want to see okay i
want to see one of the guys and the love
is blind
he falls in love oh looks don't matter i
don't care
because he's assuming he knows it's a
reality show he's he assumes it's some
dime that he's he's gonna be matched up
with and then and then one of these back
lizzo background dancers comes out 300
pounds in spandex that is one marriage
that will stay together he can't there's
nothing he can do because he has to he
has to be like body affirming so he's
gonna be stuck in this marriage forever
now
this person that would be that would be
fun okay go ahead
i don't want to be doing this with
anyone but you
this is the first time in a long time
that i'm open to love
spending time with you and getting to
know you it just feels natural
so what are you guys expecting from this
island
oh i guess that means too hot to handle
is back
i know that's lana no kissing
no heavy petting
and no sex of any kind
this is
the ultimate [ __ ] block
each time the rules are broken money
will be deducted
yesterday
i love bad boys you are the bad boy play
the role
can i call my mom i want to go home
uh i don't say this to be cruel or mean
but watching that trailer i have never
in my life rooted
for a tsunami so much
just a 100 foot tidal wave crashing
through
cleansing the land that's my idea for a
reality show get all these kinds of
people onto an island
tell them it's a reality show called
like uh
boob island or whatever and then set off
a tidal wave not to kill them i wouldn't
wish that on anybody i i wouldn't i just
i just mean to startle them a little bit
maybe wash some of the
herpes and genital crabs off
and um if anybody drowns in the process
that was not the intention
for legal purposes anyway i'm in a bad
mood now
i'm upset by this
i feel drained and exhausted
and i'm dumber i actually i feel that i
am dumber than i was at the start maybe
this last one will be this will be a
bright spot to end on maybe we can we
can help
the people are real
the cases are real and the judgments are
legally binding i'm fully naked under
him i think that's the hardest part
about being a judge it's so hot
this is chrissy's sport
okay so first of all nothing happens in
that show at all like that's the trailer
for it and the one highlight is chrissy
teigen saying she's naked that's like if
i went to a restaurant and i said i said
that the highlight of the restaurant my
restaurant experience was that the
chicken was undercooked and gave me food
poisoning if that's the highlight how
low is the low light is the question
this is what i want i want a judge show
where i'm the judge
and everybody gets the death penalty for
coming on the show the death penalty
for everyone the fact that you would
come to a judge show in the first place
to settle your problem means you deserve
the death penalty this has gotten really
dark hasn't it my mind is in a dark
place no and um
you thank my producers for that for all
of this
this is all their fault
okay let's stop now i'm done
[Music]